damit kommt meine lieben freunde ich
darf euch heute recht herzlich
willkommen bei uns einer neuen episode
tuesday
es ist montag ja start war direkt mit
positiven vibes jens video keinem ort
dieser welt selbst seine zukünftige frau
wie spritzig mit dem am 24
[Musik]
alles klar dinge alleine gucken wir
heute hier in berlin es hat viele
gerechnet und jetzt bin hier mit meiner
regenschauer war drehte hat viele
gerechnet und aber deswegen ist weiß von
oben nach unten und ich bin mir mit
meiner regen regen silvia
immer wenn ich nur ein kleines loch in
der jeans hatte war es einfach direkt
seligkeit wild hog ich glaube der
polizist bisschen salzig geworden weil
der typ der ihn gestreichelt hat sehr
nah an seiner waffe war also ich habe
auch eine wasserkanone und ist dafür da
um weihnachtsbaum abzuschießen und der
sinn dahinter frage ich mich auch
also hat freigesprochen
und er hatte bilder und er hat
freigesprochen
gähn ja dk ich hätte auch fast bei
bayern unterschrieben aber kohlschreiber
ist einfach leer gegangen ich glaube das
kleine mädchen muss man die reifen ölen
da quietscht irgendwas mit 24 das
heiraten okay ich mit 24 nicht huste
kommt kalte luft aber wenn ich poste com
warme luft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was hältst du von der schule ich mir
gekauft
seine mom haut daraus misanthrop jungen
gibt die checks und so weiter und so
fort bei meiner mama jetzt
wahrscheinlich nur gesagt stell deine
schule nicht auf den tisch du das auch
absolut ein mann gerade gewesen
unnormal guter spruch alter dem muss ich
mir merken fürs nächste mal meldeten mir
schreibt die sp in letzter zeit labil
tag wenn euch irgendwie oder irgendwo
oder was auch immer ihr steht nervt und
die person schreibt euch einfach etwas
hast du gegen mich antwortet einfach
nichts was hilft ist auch gut kenne ich
weil mir das also
[Musik]
wie gesagt
welcher typ ist so dumm und fällt auf
diese scheiße also das video schön und
gut aber die wichtigste frage ist
einfach es annika also ich frage mich
einfach warum annika wieder nicht da ist
was sagt man wenn man von einer person
namens nick geschlagen wird ali k
wegen annika er sieht so aus wie wenn
man früher bei seinen puppen den kopf so
ein
ich hatte keine dicker und schillig
brauchst kein pool kaufen oder wenn es
weg soll einfach in reis legen täglich
unaufgefordert mit bildern schickt mir
lieber eure ziele wünsche ich würde mich
da auch zur verfügung stellen
was ist passiert wir vergessen nicht
einfach am penn und ja mich nicht
aufgeweckt
[Musik]
immer so immer wurde ja man wird immer
angespuckt von so zitronen limetten
orangen es ein richtiges buch früchte
kennt ihr noch mehr sport vollautomaten
tomaten können richtig l spucken
du kleine sowie bald schließen sich der
gegner und ball
das ist sondern richtig klassischer und
wo das herrchen der villa spielen
vielleicht ein bein 80 mio
das verstehe ich jetzt nicht also den
sound habe ich noch mein hobby hat ja
gar keinen reißverschluss trotzdem ist
er extrem soft flaschen hatten
supercoolen fit wo gibt's denn die halt
stopp den gibt's da noch gar nicht mehr
kommt erst am 21
februar um 15 uhr in den luca shops
zusammen mit einem mega coolen t shirt
denn ich habe am 21
im februar geburtstag er gibt dir jetzt
seine hand und dann seid ihr schönen
lauf
auch passen also ein spaß ja bitte hört
auf bilder zu schicken
[Musik]
wasser ist sowieso aber wisst ihr uns
nicht gesund ist sich über
übergewichtige lustig zu machen weil es
ein augenmenschen
[Musik]
diese fetten weg ohne zu sagen dass
eltern aber auch das wird jetzt extrem
witzig weil es überhaupt keine note
trifft oder inhalt ist gebe lieber
etikett allein www bpb
das kann ich auch also leute
vorstellen wird mit einer kühlschrank
mikrowelle wasser jochen küchenrollen
bettler ich latina erfährt oder die
dunstabzugshaube mir die waschbecken
nicht zu vergessen das böse und weder
korrekt dass du mir deine wohnung
vorgestellt hatte ich kann ja auch mal
meine vorstellen die als müllhalde ich
nicht und dann stelle ich das heute
wieder zu beenden meine lieben freunde
männer ihr ticket you stayed bzw heute
dann halt tik tok monday weil er
eigentlich ist
[Musik]